black just step back with a knight check
and
two pawn advantage you can push this
pawn you can just defend it with your
knight
yeah two pawns is too much white's
bishop cannot sacrifice itself for both
of those pawns
the knight goes back safety first
approach and napoleon she turns off the
light
and i bet that has to do with the fly
yeah
what's that rhyme i know it was an old
lady i was a little lady he swallowed a
fly
i don't know why i just wanted to fly
perhaps she'll die
oh and then it carries on and she uh
eats a spider oh wow and then a bird
hopefully there are no spiders or birds
in the pontiac's office
it's a crazy rhyme what can i say
all right well it's dark ryan pognacci
is sitting and it's kind of dark
i guess on the board as well for him is
there any way he can save this
no i don't think he can actually white's
bishop might well get trapped
maybe wesley can step forward with the
pawn here and prevent the white bishop
from running away to safety